hello and welcome to hot take the show
where I take a controversial stance and
try to justify it a little while ago I
asserted the position that the older
Dragon Ball movies before battle of gods
were for lack of a better term to me
personally subpar which led me to send
out a tweet asking you guys to suggest
some of your favorite fills for me to
review and so far I've seen Bojack
unbound videos revenge
rack of the Dragon and Fusion reborn
however today I am gonna be looking at
bro Lee the legendary Super Saiyan
dead zone the world's strongest and path
to power in the comments of my last
video these came up time and time again
is recommended so let's see how they
measure up starting with 1996 is Dragon
Ball film path to power I'm gonna come
out and say it this is the single best
animated Dragon Ball film after Dragon
Ball super bro Lee I think it is better
than battle of gods resurrection F and
even fusion reborn in many respects the
action scenes are spectacular but this
film honestly never stops moving even in
the comedic and quieter scenes whether
it be the vast types of machinery used a
single pole digging into the ground or
someone taping a wing mirror to a
vehicle this film is top to bottom
beginning to end
detail and effort and honestly that
brought a lot of life to the characters
of this film additionally this film is
actually feature-length 2 with a run
time of 1 hour and 20 minutes and
despite the vast majority of it being
made up of Dragon Balls early story
beats there's enough different both
visually and narrative Lee to warrant at
least one viewing with that said the
film does have its downsides as I've
said the vast majority of the film's
runtime is comprised of scenes taken or
inspired from the manga itself the first
11 minutes of the film are spent
animating the first 23 pages of the
manga itself and seems like muscle power
Yamcha alongs introduction as well as
Master Roshi's first appearance are
included depicting minor or significant
changes from the original story and
despite not including characters like
chichi ox King or any of the other
colorful characters of early Dragonball
they made absolutely certain to include
every lewd
rude and crass shot of Bulma they could
personally this is less of a problem I
have with this film specifically and
more so one I have with the anime
industry in Japan in general and I
honestly think stuff like this is
holding it back from being taken
seriously on a much broader worldwide
stage with all of that said I want to
treat this film as a film and not an
adaptation of the series so do I think
that this film could stand alone on its
own absolutely for the first half of the
feature the story focuses on introducing
Goku Bulma along Yamcha and port to the
audience by the way this movie makes
Yamcha look intimidating for a few
seconds just let that sink in in trying
to track down the seven dragonballs they
find themselves engaging with the red
ribbon army and android 8 android 8
refuses to fight resulting in Goku
building a relationship with the Android
however my only gripe with the film
comes at the end during the final battle
where there's tons of even more gorgeous
animation than we've seen already
Android 8 shows up out of nowhere to
make this safe for Goku destroying
himself in the process once Goku
realizes his friend is gone he gets
angry and boom the movie is over now
there's nothing really wrong with that
on a technical level but I would have
liked more of a reason for Android 8 and
Goku to be so fond of one another
however with that said it's not
necessarily that much of a stretch in
the first place Goku around this time is
very innocent
and Android 8 never had a friend before
we'd always said and done if you look at
this film as its own unique standalone
story I think it works exceptionally
well considering what it has to work
with while films like fusion reborn were
really fun and enjoyable
I thought they felt more like extended
episodes of the show than an actual film
in its own right path to power both from
a visual production point of view and a
narrative one to some extent is much
more of a total film than Fusion reborn
was so as of writing this path to power
takes the number one spot in my rankings
of the film so far but will that change
with the introduction of the next film
the dead zone movie a Dragonball Z film
from 1989 and I'm just gonna say it
flat-out I really didn't like this one
while the story is simple and doesn't
have too many moving parts there were so
many things concerning the story I had
issues with I couldn't help but be taken
out time and time again but that's not
to say that there aren't things I
enjoyed within the film itself it has an
exceptionally efficient and strong
opening setting mistakes early
establishing the villain and taking out
two big players right off the bat for so
I thought I also thoroughly enjoyed
seeing chichi standing up for herself
physically while trying to defend her
son gohan not some damsel in distress
and I really appreciated that the plot
in a nutshell is that garlic jr. wants
to take over the world and gain
immortality using the Dragon Balls of
course in his effort to gather all of
the orbs go on for some reason gets
wrapped up in all of the chaos and taken
to garlics castle which brings me to all
the problems I had with the film how did
garlic's forces know where any of the
Dragon Balls were when they attacked
Gohan's family for their dragon ball why
didn't they just take the Hat Gohan was
wearing instead of Gohan wearing the Hat
that can run away and they even said
that they would bring him back early in
the film it's only later that garlic jr.
learns of Gohan's hidden power and wants
to keep him why did they drag a crime
child all the way to their hideout if
all they wanted was the Dragon Ball it's
like going to a clothing store with the
intention of stealing or shoplifting
something and running out with a person
wearing the shirt you wanted it doesn't
make any sense and it's a crippling plot
hole in this movie the indication in the
first scene was that comi and piccolo
had been removed entirely from the
picture which begs the question why
would garlic jr. and his henchmen tried
to end their lives knowing that if they
did the Dragon Balls would vanish and
garlic would never be able to enact his
plan it's honestly like the people
writing this don't know the rules of the
world they're writing for additionally
there's another scene where our heroes
are trying to retrieve Gohan who is up
on a high balcony this is the problem
for Goku for some reason despite him
jumping exceptionally high moments prior
and that's not even mentioning that he
doesn't even think to use Kinta or
Nimbus and finally the Garlic jr. fight
at the end takes a ton of visual cues
and ideas from piccolo and Goku's battle
with Raddatz most obvious being the
weighted clothing reveal from both
fighters and Gohan's last-minute save at
the end
honestly all in all this film being only
41 minutes long feels more like a couple
of bad episodes than an actual movie
there are some nice action moments
dotted throughout with some nostalgic
animation that I loved but the plot is
confused contradictory and amateurish at
times I hope to call me that the next
film I watch is better than this one
this is yet another world of the Dragon
Ball films that has a pretty simple plot
a villain by the name of dr. wheelo
appears in the form of a brain after
using the Dragon Balls piccolo Master
Roshi and boma are all taken by this
villain who is essentially looking for
the best body to act as a vessel for his
consciousness therefore he is looking
for all together now the world's
strongest once word reaches Goku that
Roshi and boma had been taken by this
villain he makes a beeline for the snowy
region the action in this film is
honestly spectacular for the most part
and features some of the most iconic
Dragon Ball film battles I'm sure most
of you will recognize a lot of these
clips from the original opening for
Dragon Ball Z that we would receive in
the West there's even some action with
Roshi that is honestly always a delight
to see it's these early battles in the
headquarters that are the film's
strongest I think there's tons of
creative choreography with Goku fighting
on the ice against spiky balls and the
character bowtie most characters to
ideas from however there's a section
towards the middle of the film where the
pace comes to a me brah stop for yet
more exposition to be given which brings
me to my first major criticism of this
film we get dr. willows backstory and
plan too many times during the run time
I've spoken in the past that other
Dragon Ball films like these have been
crippled by their short run time however
this film at times feels as though they
took a 40 minute script and tried to
stretch it to one hour now that's not to
say that this film is boring but the
entire Gohan sequence towards the
beginning didn't need to be there at all
and dr. willows plan didn't need to be
explained a half-dozen times in
different ways from different characters
as I've said before the animation is
honestly fantastic it has some wonderful
moments a highlight for sure has to be
the group Kamehameha and Goku's frequent
use of my favorite technique a kaio-ken
however once the final battle
between the giant robot and Goku shows
up and know their issue becomes
impossible to ignore for me the majority
of the fight is comprised of set pieces
and shots that are lifted almost
directly from the Saiyans ugh the
similarities have been present
throughout the film but this last act is
so similar to Vegeta's fight with Goku
it's distracting
honestly the action in this film is the
best I've seen from these Ori DBZ movies
but the story is maybe too simple and
the plot isn't there to justify the
one-hour runtime
I think personally and now with that out
of the way you know what time it is it's
time for Broly the legendary Super
Saiyan jokes aside I'm not sure if I
need to run through the plot of this one
it's pretty well known through memes and
even team for start but for those that
don't know here's the skinny King Kai
notices a massive power has blown up the
South galaxy and makes contact with Goku
to investigate the issue while this is
happening trunks go on and the rest of
the gang are invited to new planet
Vegeta where are Vegeta has been asked
to reign as king and to defeat the
legendary Super Saiyan there we discover
two new sands para goose and his son
brewing however it's a trap he's really
strong they fight the end and that'll do
for this week see you all in the next
video bye okay so this film is a lot
better and in many ways a lot worse than
I expected at the same time the comedic
moments towards the beginning works
surprisingly well and Goku is an
absolute treat to see in these scenarios
with chichi I also enjoyed the structure
of Goku Vegeta's plot lines working side
by side with both Vegeta and Goku
pursuing the legendary Super Saiyan that
has been wreaking havoc on the universe
however before long the story moves on
to my favorite part of these films the
exposition dump it's revealed that para
goose is trying to control broglie's
power using a remote and that broglie's
entire motivation to attack and dislike
Goku is due to him crying in the nursery
next in I know most of you know this
already and even I did four years but
Wow even just hearing it now it just
really resonates as a nothing motivation
I have no idea what boy's personality is
like he has virtually no lines in this
film beyond screaming and the word
Kakarot certainly none that shed any
discernible light and what kind of
character he is personally at times he
seems calm and mellow others he seems
psychotically evil I guess whatever the
story needs him to be with in this film
para guess
number of long-winded expository
monologues that served to fill us in on
his motivations and their origins and
honestly I always found these to be
really boring this is something the
latest Rolly film rectified by showing
us their origin rather than telling it
to us however as the action ramps up
brouilly eats all of the Jeter's most
powerful attacks without blinking
concluding in one of the most iconic and
recognizable moments of the film the
visuals in this movie are stunning and
the action is genuinely fantastic it's
no wonder that this film set a trend for
the art department moving forward this
was the first film that employed
character designs by tadayoshi umemura
who would eventually go on to provide
designs for the Buu saga and years later
for Dragon Ball super the second half of
the film is pretty much wall-to-wall
action from trunks Gohan Vegeta and a
whole lot of all-in-all I actually
really enjoyed Goku in this film and a
lot of the comedy had employed worked
really well for me I especially loved
that Goku teleports into croons punch
now that's some good slapstick the
opening scenes are fun and the action is
enjoyable to a certain extent but the
motivations and personalities introduced
outside the main cast are extremely
one-dimensional and at times overtly
boring I don't think I'd watch this film
again but if you haven't seen it and
loved Dragonball there's definitely
something to enjoy so I have now seen
eight Dragon Ball films in total and
this is how I would rank them my least
favorite so far has been dead zone in a
close seventh place I would put Bojack
unbound after that I would put probably
the legendary Super Saiyan coolers
revenge takes up the middle world's
strongest NAB's the fourth spot wrath of
the Dragon comes in at number three
fusion reborn comes in at number two and
path to power so far it has been my
favorite of the Dragon Ball films most
of these films including fusion reborn
which I really liked would work just as
well if not better as episodes within a
TV show very few of these old Dragonball
films actually feel like films and most
of them to me at least feel rushed or
have massive glaring issues craft of the
Dragon however that will do it for this
week don't forget to leave a comment
explaining why I'm wrong and subscribe
for more whacky Dragon Ball videos thank
you so much for watching
[Music]